Colorado Supreme Court takes Trump off
the ballot with the flimsiest and most
ridiculous legal reasoning you've ever
heard the sociology Professor testifies
that based on Donald Trump's statements
from 2016 to 2020 we can conclude that
all of his comments on January 6 about
fighting to preserve the country and so
on were really coded language designed
to incite a mob to commit acts of
violence at the capital that's the
argument and this disqualification
Clause says you cannot be on the ballot
for president or you cannot serve as
president if you have participated in
Insurrection or Rebellion against the
United States and so I would think that
regardless of what your politics are
what your party is everybody should
agree that this is a question of law
that's got to be settled by the courts
everybody should agree that this should
be settled by the courts well actually
no four judges selected by Democrat
Governors should not in fact settle the
issue of whether American citizens can
vote for the clear front runner in a
presidential election